The joe rogan experience with one of the things that you've realized.
And I've realized over the course of our friendship,
I mean Eddie's been my best friend since I think 2000.
We started hanging out in 2018 which is,
comes back to the,
it comes back to the story of the twister because it is,
that'd be we became good friends.
Um,
I was,
uh,
getting,
private lessons when I first started doing Jujitsu.
I was a blue belt onto this dude.
I won't say his name is a very nice guy,
but it's an,
I'm gonna say something negative and I was,
because I was getting a private lessons from him all the time.
He was the only guy that I was rolling with and I wasn't really learning nearly
as much as I thought.
I thought like if your kickboxing,
and like you say,
if you get a chance to work out with rob came in,
it's way better to work out with rob came in one on one than it is to go to a
private class.
Like he's going to correct all your technique.
So I thought that would be the case with Jujitsu.
Like I would get really good going to class and ain't like that at Eddie was the
first person to tell me.
And uh,
Eddie came to a,
a,
one of the private lessons that I was having one Silvio and we rolled around a
little bit and white away.
He got me in a twister and I had no idea what the fuck he's doing.
All of a sudden he hooks my knee with his left leg and his left foot goes under
his right knee and he rolls forward under his left shoulder and I'm spinning
around like a top.
And next thing I know he's got my arm wrapped around his neck and he's fucking
pulling on my neck like this.
I was like,
what the fuck did you just do?
Like I had been doing Jujitsu for two years and I had no idea what the fuck you
just did to me.
And I was like,
God damn.
And you're like,
I'll teach you all this shit.
I was like,
dude,
teach me this shit.
And that's how we became friends.
And that's also how I started smoking pot.
You know,
I was on the Mark Marin podcast the other day and this came up.
Um,
you know,
I,
I've thought that marijuana and all that stuff was for losers.
I thought that it just made you a loser.
You're just going to become unmotivated.
You're not going to get anything done.
You're going to be a dummy and just sit and watch TV.
That's not what I wanted,
man.
I wanted to make sure.
We're like our friend bud.
We have a good friend,
but who's like super fucking go get her.
You know,
bud is a great guy.
He,
he's the one to put together the TV show to build that car,
that Barracuda.
And he's also the one who did my garage,
like an MMA garage.
She's always got like a bunch of different TV shows going on and he's a fucking
go getter and you and I are always like,
dude,
please just let us get you high.
You how many times more than Dr drew more than anybody.
How many times we've been having this conversation with him and he's always
like,
after I make my first million and then he makes his first million,
or like,
I'm still looking,
I'm not gonna.
I don't wanna slow down now.
Like he just does not want to slow it down and we're like,
it ain't about slowing down man.
It's not about,
I'm not slowing down.
I haven't slowed down at all.
I work more now than I ever did before.
I'm a busy mother fucker.
That's it.
This is not an annoying goddamn stereotype that potheads or are lazy.
We get a lot of shit done,
dude.
I'm doing two podcasts a week.
I'm writing a book,
I'm writing my standup comedy,
I'm performing standup comedy and I'm doing standup.
I'm doing the commentary for the number one mixed martial arts organization in
the fucking world,
and I'm training Jujitsu and I'm doing kettlebells and I'm raising kids and I
play pool every night and I got to surf the Internet and I've got to beat off.
There's a lot of shit going on,
man.
It's a lot of God damn time.
I'm not lazy at all.
I squeezed it all out every day.
So when people say that potheads you know that it makes you lazy.
It's just a stereotype man.
And that was a stereotype that I,
before I met you,
man,
I do sleep till about 10 45 every day.
So what time do you go to bed?
Two or three.
Yeah,
that's like eight hours.
That's what you're supposed to get,
man.
Most of these people were in bed at 10 o'clock at night.
That's why when they get up at six o'clock in the morning,
they were all impressed with themselves.
My,
yeah,
bitch,
I slept a one 30 in the afternoon.
But where were you at 5:00 AM?
I was writing the greatest bit I've ever written in my life.
Okay?
That's why I write my best shit.
I was in the fucking isolation tank traveling through the universe.
All right.
That's what I was doing while you were sleeping.
So then give me a hard time because my time is different than your time.
Like somehow or another,
you know you,
you were fucking doing yoga at 5:00 AM so you're the king.
Fuck you.
Stupid.
And it's all based on farmers anyway.
It's based on farms.
You have to fucking get up early.
That's nonsense asleep.
The crazy thing is a Joe and I,
before we started smoking weed,
we were totally against it.
We would bag on stoners and we thought it made you stupid.
And I would talk so much shit on stone.
Or is that at 28?
That's when I found out the truth.
That's when I reaped the benefits of marijuana.
And then when I met Joe,
he was so funny.
I thought this guy's got a smoke pot.
He's so funny.
Like I go see him,
you know,
do stand up at the comedy store.
And I'm like,
that's that dude who trains at John Jack Machado's.
He trains at my school.
Hey,
what's up dude,
I train at your school.
And I was like,
watch them do comedy.
And I thought he was critical.
He's got a smoking.
Eddie and I had a bunch of fortuitous meetings just out of the,
out of the blue before we became friends.
At one time.
Eddie's eyes aren't so good.
And one time we were at a,
uh,
at Mel's diner and it was late at night,
man,
it was like one o'clock in the morning.
And I'm like,
Yo,
ed,
hey,
Yo Eddie.
He's like,
man,
who's this motherfucker talking to me,
I'm going to have to fight this dude in front of my chick that's remember that.
Oh my God,
you remember that?
Yeah.
You taught,
I was like some dude who's just fucking with you.
So I had it down.
I'm like,
I thought you were.
Cause I was with the check and I thought you were saying something to the check.
Yeah.
You didn't hear what I was saying and you can't see that good.
So he couldn't see me from a distance.
So by the time I came up to your table,
Chris's mother Fucker,
and then you'll,
oh,
hey dude,
I didn't watch news radio.
And at that point it was before a fear factor.
So I never watched news radio.
And so I was like,
okay,
I hear he's an actor or something,
like I barely remember it.
But then when I saw you at the college,
that was by luck to,
you didn't come there with me.
You just came.
Yeah.
It was just I want to go see come cause right when I started smoking weed,
I began to appreciate comedy way more cause we'd better all of a sudden my mind
figured out how to write comedy.
Right.
When I started smoking weed,
I never understood.
I was fascinated with comedy,
but I never understood how they put bits together.
I didn't understand the setup.
I didn't understand the structure of comedy.
But as soon as I start smoking weed,
I'm like,
I know where they're doing.
I know what they're doing now they're doing this and they're taking that and
then do it.
So I understood the basic foreign layer.
So I just became fascinated and then I saw you.
I'm like,
does that do for my Jujitsu school?
He's an actor and you killed me.
You were just,
you were all nothing but dick jokes and like relationship jokes,
chick jokes,
dating Joe.
But you would kill in it.
And then when you came,
you walked off stage.
I'm like,
hey dude,
what's up dude?
I go,
you fucking were awesome.
And then we,
then that's when he invited me to give him a private or something.
That was after when those taken privates with that dude.
Yeah.
And then you came down to class and then,
and then the,
the pot smoking began.
That was it.
They were see people that are in relationships and get mad at everything all
day.
Girls Nitpick it guys.
And the guy fucking fires back and you go,
well you guys are not handling this so well.
And then you guys are handling this kind of silly.
You don't have to do this.
You know,
that's hard.
It's hard to watch,
man.
Especially when people have kids.
Dude.
That's when it gets hard,
dude.
That's when it gets hard.
Are going to front.
I got in front of Scott a kid and him and his wife,
the um,
the,
you seem,
they seem like they don't like each other.
They seem like they're,
they're both upset at each other.
Do I know?
Yeah,
I know he talked him.
It's unfortunate.
You know,
it's like,
God damn,
you guys get this beautiful situation here.
You look should love each other.
Come on,
get it together.
You know what?
Either one of them smoke weed.
There might be a part of the problem,
right?
I think everybody needs a little weed man.
A little perspective.
It's a little perspective enhancer.
You know,
don't you think when you smoke with me like smoking weed with your girl,
it doesn't matter.
This is a nice thing.
The best thing,
right?
It's like you,
you like,
you chilled together,
you know,
you hang out together.
It feels better when he kissed each other.
You know,
it's like a,
a super sensitivity drug.
You know,
it makes you super sensitive.
I mean,
he makes you really,
really like that person.
You know,
all their good qualities get accentuated.
You really appreciate them.
Almost like you're seeing with new eyes or you can get really paranoid,
you know,
or freak the fuck out all the dot.
Guys.
I was watching your phantom buzzes for guys texting her and her phone.
Oh Man,
I've,
I've had some serious anxiety attacks now.
I was watching cops last night and it was like I've had at least five first.
The biggest anxiety like,
sorry to break your,
hold onto that thought.
Brian.
I want to hear these anxiety attacks.
I never smoked pot growing up just but once a year.
Sorry Brian.
Get in there.
Don't be scared.
That's perfect dude.
It's early.
It's only eight 20 man shows us one star for two hours getting their son.
Plus we've got to go get some food after this.
We gotta hurry.
People are getting start getting here at nine.
Why are they getting here?
An hour and a half early did do the chronicle's.
Oh,
who's coming at nine
I just told everyone to come in as close as nice as possible.
Oh,
okay.
So they'll all be here around 10 like last time in high school,
I didn't smoke weed,
like I said,
once a year at a party or something and I would always get paranoid wasn't into
it at all.
I did not like smoking weed.
It all growing up.
11th grade lunch,
there was a big stoner crowd.
There's probably like a hundred people in the stoner crowd and everyone thought
I was a stoner cause I hung out in the stoner crowd.
But if you look closely,
I was like on edge.
I wasn't really in with those guys,
man.
That wasn't really it.
It appeared I was,
but actually wasn't hanging out with them.
It's just me and three other guys on the side.
And one day I got pulled into the crowd and they're passing around a joint and I
said,
fuck it.
I didn't want to be a Douche.
I was kind of like stoked that they pulled me in,
smoked a little bit of weed,
is that lunch.
And I walked to my next class and I said,
who knew?
Knew,
knew dude,
dude.
I sat down.
I was,
yeah,
exactly.
Boom,
boom.
So it was history and I'm sitting there as US history.
I'm so fucked up out of my mind.
I'm like,
I freaked out.
I was getting paranoid.
So I thought,
how am I going to get through this class?
So I call,
I'll just look straight.
Don't look at anybody,
just look straight.
Don't do nothing.
I go,
Oh my God,
I'm freaking out,
but I'm not.
No one's going to know.
No one's going to go.
And then I looked to the side and there's,
people are looking back on
my eyes got fucking,
they said there were people were like turning around pointing at my eyes and I'm
like,
fuck,
don't look.
Please don't.
Everyone's laughing.
I'm like,
fuck.
And then some girl handed me or compacts with,
look at your eyes.
I looked at my eyes and they were so red.
It was fucking like a Zombie's eyes.
Would you,
you have,
um,
you have contacts.
Did you have contact and have contacts back then?
You have glasses,
like black frame?
Yes,
I did.
I did work every now and then.
Every now and then.
But not to school.
Fuck No.
But my,
I looked at,
at my eyes and I freaked out.
I just stood up and walked out of class and when to the bathroom and I sat on
the bathroom floor.
Meanwhile,
everyone's in cloud and I sat on the bathroom floor just freaking out,
like just panicking like I was on a rack or something,
just sitting on the bathroom floor.
The teacher calls the campus cop,
total asshole,
big ass mustache,
total asshole.
He opens the door,
he,
he opens the luxury.
You put those two together,
so,
so big ass must never forget him.
He opens the bathroom door and I'm sitting down and he opens.
It goes,
what are you doing in here?
And I immediately started crying.
I'm like,
Ooh.
Like I pretended like I was sick and everybody had known that I like,
I was fucked up on weed because the teacher knew that everyone was laughing.
I just walk out of class.
He grabbed me by the neck,
pick me up and drag me to the principal's office and I'm like,
I just started crying.
So just pretending that I was sick and he knew I wasn't sick.
So he brought me to the principal's office.
He had a to pay on.
It was awesome and he was really cool.
He goes,
what's wrong?
I go,
I'm sick.
I need a bed.
Corn Dog,
I'm sick.
And he goes,
and the cop was like,
it wasn't buying it at all,
but the principal just looked at me and said,
all right,
let him go home.
And he just let me go home.
And I just walked home like all fucked up.
I got home,
just laid down on my bed and I'll never forget looking at the VCR clock,
just watching the minutes click by just,
I couldn't wait.
It just seemed like it was going to last forever.
Just watching the clock please feeling go away.
I hate this feeling.
I hated it.
Yeah.
I only got high maybe a dozen
times before I started getting high with you over the course of my whole life.
But one time I did when I was 15 with this girl that I dated,
she was a,
she,
it was her idea and my friend Josh,
we all three of us got high together and I was probably like 1514 maybe 1415 and
I stole my dad's.
We'd,
he had some super strong weed,
man.
I mean,
it was,
I don't,
I mean,
I was a little kid,
right.
And I don't know how we smoked it.
I don't remember anything,
but what I do remember is just lying on the couch.
My whole body just tangling,
like little electrical circuits are going off and my whole body and then I was
time traveling.
I would,
I would be on my back on the couch and then boom,
I'd be in front of the fridgerator and I had no recollection of how I got there.
It was like instantly I appeared in front of the refrigerator and then boom,
I was in the bedroom and I couldn't remember walking to the bedroom.
It's like my short term memory was so fucked that every few steps,
my whole brain just rebooted and I'm like,
how did I get here?
Erased all the steps up to get to that point.
There was no memory.
I mean my brain was fucked.
We both fucked.
We're giggling,
but I was scared of weed after that for awhile.
I didn't do it again for for a long time.
That was a,
that was a scary one.
I hated it,
man.
I couldn't believe that people could function and smoke weed.
I didn't get it guys in the bands that I was in growing up,
it was always one star or two stoners and every time he made a mistake playing
bass,
I'll be like,
blame the weed and go see you coming in and fucking stone that fucking weed.
Just fucks your brain up is,
you know what I would do with Andy Dick on Newsradio.
Really?
They would come in high and he wouldn't remember his lyrics.
I'm like,
the freak is high again.
Like you'd be all pissed.
I was totally man.
I was such a dick to stoners growing.
Oh,
me too dick.
I was fully,
you're addicted people.
I'm sorry.
You're,
you're addicted.
The people that you're afraid of yourself being,
you know,
I was afraid of being a stoner.
You know what's interesting about that fight was that was the first fight that
Brock overing fight a couple weeks.
So that was the first UFC that I've seen as a spectator in Vegas.
It since 2003 or two.
Oh Wow.
That was the first one.
I was so wasted.
I got so drunk.
Everyone's buying me shots do from Toronto or buying me shots.
I'm like drinking Blue Moon Beers all night.
I blacked out at the end of the night,
passed out of the hotel.
I woke up,
I knew Overeem one,
but I didn't know exactly how he want,
but I knew he wasn't,
I had no recollection of Nick Diaz.
Donald's Serone at all.
Really?
I didn't know how that went at all.
Man.
You're tripping on acid because you look so fucked up.
Yeah,
man,
it was,
I was,
I was having so much fun.
The greatest show ever invented.
Yeah.
The Indian came out in full force,
man.
I scalped a couple of months for
those that don't know.
That's a Joey Diaz always said about Eddie Bravo.
Give him,
give him a couple of drinks that Indian comes out because apparently according
to Joey Diaz,
Indians and Mexicans are related.
They're all,
it's all the same blood line dog
and you know,
um,
you know,
if I drink too much,
like there's a lot of people that have Indians inside of them that come out.
If the infant comes out,
if the enemy comes out,
odds are I'm going to forget 95% of the night I've been,
I've been in some situations with Eddie where I had to like hold this fucking
hand and walk him home.
What about Germany?
Germany was a couple of different ones.
How about England?
When I had to wake you up,
we were banging on the fucking door banging on his door,
man.
I had security come out cause I thought he might be in England for the UFC.
Yeah,
we were in for the UFC.
It's time to take the flight,
you know.
And I always say,
you know,
hey man,
we got a flight in like an hour.
You know,
you,
you're cool.
You're going to pat.
Yeah.
Fucking cause we're trying to stay up all night.
We try to stay up all night so we could sleep on the plane.
So um,
it's in the morning and we got to go.
The car is waiting for us when my shit,
we've got to get to that airport earlier.
It's an international flight.
I've got passports and shit.
Bang,
Bang.
Knocked on the door.
No Eddie,
Bang,
Bang.
Knocked on the door.
No 80 call cell phones.
No,
Eddie,
go downstairs,
have the phone,
the desk call his room,
no answer.
So I said,
listen,
I'm worried about my friends safety.
He was,
uh,
he was intoxicated last night.
And um,
you know,
I want to make sure that he's okay.
Can you open the door?
They opened the door.
This motherfucker is sleeping with the lights on.
The lights were on and he's on the bed completely unconscious with his fucking
cowboy boots on.
Just asleep in there.
Eddie.
Eddie,
you open up your eyes.
You Go,
what's up dude?
It's just like that simple,
that simple.
It's me and two security dudes at were screaming,
Hey Eddie.
And you just pop your head up,
subdued.
You were blasted.
Nothing.
Nothing,
man,
you were that I help you stuff your shit.
I remember you had a shoe in your backpack and you're like,
why do I have a shoe in my backpack?
Yeah,
that's the Indian right there.
Right there.
Oh my God,
you're bringing is swimming in a world of soup.
I was fucking alcohol soup.
I was hammered it.
Oh my God,
look at you.
Look at that face.
That's the,
that's the best.
The best story is Germany.
Man.
It was so fucked up that you got to write a blog about Germany was so crazy.
Yeah,
Texas too.
Well,
well here's,
here's a Germany in Germany.
It was like,
I dunno,
maybe like we had to leave at like seven o'clock in the morning and a five
o'clock in the morning.
I talked to Eddie on the phone.
I go,
dude,
what are you doing man?
I go,
we got to leave in like two hours.
I'm a power through.
I'm going to power through
power through.
I go,
are you still awake?
I you,
yeah,
Dude.
Awesome.
How was that part yet?
He was still out partying.
So a,
I go downstairs,
I eat breakfast and uh,
I,
uh,
say,
all right,
let me go get eddy.
I can't get him.
He's not in his room,
not answering his phone.
I,
I the same thing.
I have them open up his door.
He's not in his room.
He's gone.
So I'm like,
shit,
where the fuck could he be?
So then I go downstairs and I look around and I'm
like,
I keep calling his phone.
He's not answering.
And finally I say to the guy that's,
um,
taking care of the cars.
I said,
you've got a car for Joe Rogan.
And the guy says,
oh yeah,
he left.
I go,
what?
And he goes,
he left.
I go,
no,
I'm Joe Rogan.
You guys have a car from me.
He goes,
oh my God.
Somebody already said there were Joe Rogan and they left.
I go,
who the fuck?
What did he look like?
He goes,
I had long hair and tattoos.
I'm like,
mother fucker.
And he told them that he was me.
He's in his car,
blacked out,
drunk,
blacked out is already an hour on the road.
Let me,
let me,
let me take it from there and say what happened unless I had partied all night,
man,
me and Jason Uk,
Jason McNabb,
we,
he was just getting me hammered all night.
And I don't remember all I remember the last thing I remember was part taking
shots at some clubs,
last thing.
And then fast forward to me waking up in the back of this car with my,
my backpack in my suitcase,
like in the back of this car.
And Joe Rogan is calling me.
So I wake up,
it's bright.
And I'm like,
how the fuck did I get back here?
Joe's calling me and I answered,
I'm like,
Joe,
you fucking took my car.
I hung up the phone and I asked the driver,
I'm like,
where are we going?
He's like,
dude,
we're on the auto bond dude.
He's flying down the Autobahn.
He looks back,
he's like,
we're going to the airport.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
How the fuck did this happen?
So I'm trying to remember what the fuck happened.
I opened up my,
my,
uh,
my backpack and I always put my shoes,
my extra shoes in my suitcase,
always I pocket certainly all the time.
There's one shoe in my backpack and I,
and I always keep my computer in my backpack.
I'm like,
where's my computer?
My computer is in my suitcase.
So in a drunken stupor I just must have just grabbed everything,
put shit in like a Zombie pack.
Shit up like a fucking idiot.
And I woke,
I wake up in the back of this card and then I find that Joe kept calling and I
didn't know what to say.
I didn't know what the fuck was going on.
I needed time to think.
So I finally answered.
I go,
dude,
I'm sorry.
I don't know how this happened.
I have no idea how I ended up in the back of this car.
We get,
you know,
and he ended up getting a cab and at the airport,
Joe is so mad at me,
he wouldn't talk to me.
He was so pissed off.
I was just so ridiculous.
It was the second time in a row we went traveling internationally.
The second time I had a babysitter who was from England to this.
It was just like,
Jesus,
man,
you had to write a blog about it.
And I had a,
well it's you.
You're the first guy that I ever met where I used to sell.
You know,
people say,
Oh man,
I blackout when I get truck.
Shut up their chain.
Blacking out.
You just pretending you're black and now cause it makes it convenient.
I didn't,
well you know,
I was just seeing the Indian come out man.
But like I said,
I never used to think that it was real.
I used to think that people would say that they blackout drunk and like,
come on man.
But I've looked into Eddie's eyes and I see durables.
I see dribble eyes like you ever look at a dribble size.
They're just black and dark and you don't know what's going on there.
Mostly nothing.
You know,
I didn't even know Eddie was Mexican.
I thought he was fucking with me for like the first two years.
Cause at the comedy store you're like,
I'm half Mexican.
I'm like,
no,
you're nine Mexican or you said something like that to him.
Then he used to say he was having,
yeah,
you said something else,
Japanese and health Eskimo or something like that.
It was one and he said half Japanese,
half Mexican or something.
I used to say that when I was a teenager just because I was an idiot and I want
her to see who would believe it.
And I'm like,
wow.
The,
if people believe anything.
Did you used to do that with a lot of things he used to like tell people crazy
stories and see how far you can go with it.
Man,
it still happens I think the whole,
the whole,
Ah,
why do you get into doing that,
Matt?
Do you have a hard time not doing?
You look at,
if you look at the [inaudible] and then you look in and then you look at that,
what we did on the Joe show,
like with a 10 foot zip and the templates crews,
let me tell people you don't know.
Let me tell you what we did.
We were in Denver and I was doing standup and Eddie and Tate and Brian and
Duncan.
We were all hanging out and we're walking and we went through this little
shopping area that,
what does it,
those sixth street malls that what it's called,
whatever the mall is,
whatever street it is.
Anyway,
we're going to this downtown Shami here and we see a wig store 2005 2005 was it?
And just as a goof we decided to go in this wig store and then first of all we
were high as fuck and somewhere in this wig store we came up with the idea of
having a fake band and that you guys were all going to wear these wigs.
So we all,
everyone bought wigs.
Tate had this crazy afro wig and you had this crazy wig and everyone decided
that we were going to play a band called 10 foot screws and we even announced
the band like as having an after party in town.
So people thought that it was like a real band and Eddie goes on stage,
I get off stage,
the show's over and he goes on stage with his fucking wig on and sunglasses we
have video of it's still right.
Yeah.
Well there was a whole show.
Which episode is it?
Seven yeah.
How do people find that one?
Just type in Joe show seven but you know,
all the episodes were on your website,
but since you moved the servers,
now everything is kind of weird.
It was,
there were probably getting too much bandwidth.
The premise of it was Joe wanted to put together reality show based on him going
to all these clubs across the nation and his posse and me,
Tate,
Brian,
Dunkin,
Ari,
even Larry back then,
we were all there as a producer.
We were all in this.
He was the producer.
That's what Joe was the origin of the word powerful.
When you hear me say powerful,
it's all because there's one dude,
our friend Lara.
So the show,
what was that called?
The Joe show.
We had her on your website.
We did about 11 or 12 episodes or something,
and episode seven we were in Denver.
We were trying to come up with a pet premise and then it was,
it was all about,
we just,
we just formed a band.
So Joe's on stage and we,
the way we sold it was Dunkin would get on stage and would say,
uh,
who's going to the 10 foot screws showed an I,
that's what we call it,
10 foot screws.
And that was Brian's idea.
And so we wanted to,
so Dunkin was getting everybody in the audience use of the fact that we got 10
foot screws backstage and they're playing a big show at the dome.
The Dome is next to me,
I'll know on sixth street to know point a logo.
So people were like,
oh shit,
there's a concert tonight.
I didn't know about this 10 foot screws.
Are they big?
So then it was already there too.
Who else is already wasn't Ari was,
wasn't there for Dunkin was selling it like he would,
he was like the host and he was selling it.
We got 10 foot screws tomorrow we're going to give away some tickets.
So I've got a stack of half off drinks on Tuesday night.
I got a two stacks of them and Dunkin introduced me.
I was the lead singer,
I was the total douchebag lead singer.
I was like just basically playing the singer of oasis,
but backstage.
So we,
I got up on stage and said,
who wants these tickets to the show tomorrow?
Backstage they were going nuts.
So like Paul Stanley,
I divided the crowd to one side and I said,
just like Paul Stanek okay this side,
let me hear the noise.
Like a one to let me hear the noise.
They went ahh.
And then I stopped him and I go this side,
it was just a total Paul Stanley in 1985 rebuff most bands to find that.
Finally find that and chew it up.
Just that part of it,
because when I,
when I do those tickets into the audience,
tunes were flying headfirst over tables that we're scrambling only to find that
number Tuesday night,
half off drinks and you some crazy man wearing a wig for a band that doesn't
exist yet.
So when the,
the,
the concert led out,
people had to walk by backstage.
It was a weird,
the club was set up,
weird word never walking out next to backstage.
So we had the door open and dudes are walking by gone,
where's that bad?
So we were,
we grabbed one dude and we pulled in,
we pulled in maybe three dudes and we pulled him close the door.
Now they're backstage with 10 foot screws and me and Tate are just douche bags
were total douche bag.
You remember those fucking questions you guys,
now that I'm thinking about it,
it was a great guy who got down on his knees.
Yes.
He wanted to.
He was astounded.
Do whatever to hang out with the pan.
He didn't,
he thought we were real band,
so we got them to do crazy shit.
He just wanted to hang out with the bed.
So good.
We're going to have to get on your knees.
Okay.
You're going to have to pray for us.
Pray with us.
I can no band sometimes parading them before they go on.
Thank you Jesus.
And he would replete,
thank you Jesus.
And you said for this,
dig them.
It's a psych and then he jumped up and ran away and then Tate was,
he's like six foot four.
He was so intimidating to the guided one.
I fire back,
right?
Just Tate sitting there looking like a monster,
you know,
he was scared.
And then we got girls that he probably thought that you were about to try to get
him to suck your Dick.
And I keep really probably thought that.
I mean,
do you think about it?
You're some fucking Wacko living in Colorado.
You know some dude who's willing to go to some green room for some band that he
doesn't even know,
never heard of before,
some van,
it doesn't even exist.
He's on his knees praying back and forth.
You in his head when you said that for this dictum about the saga,
he probably was not,
oh,
I fucked up.
I'll do it,
but damn I didn't.
I'm not going to like it.
And that was a great episode of too.
And then the other good episode was when we were on Boston number in Boston and
Ari Solo,
Ren Dunkin,
they both sell to the audience.
They open up and they said backstage where we're auditioning for the Joe Rogan
life stories that they're going to film.
And we're looking for guys to play Joe Rogan.
We want authentic guys from Boston.
So the guys in the audience are thinking,
Oh shit,
they're auditioning to play for play.
Joe Rogan.
I think I could do,
you could do 100 you could do it.
So people lined up and we had a fake audition.
Like I'm this bad.
Probably shouldn't talk about this cause I think what you did was illegal.
Was it?
Yeah,
I'm pretty sure he did.
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
we probably just didn't really happen.
We denied the yeah.
Yeah.
This,
this is all in another dimension.
We deny this.
We denied this parallel university.
Bravo does not seek to get suited this moment in time.
This is all fiction.
Dunkin was the director.
Never happened.
It never happened.
This didn't take place.
He can't timber saying hello.
Much respect to the Korean Zombie.
Any Bravo's wearing a Korean Zombie shirt and what this means for you.
Non MMA people.
There's a guy named chance on Junge who's a,
they call them the Korean Zombie.
That's his nickname.
And this weekend on a Saturday night at the UFC against Leonard Garcia,
he pulled off the first twister ever in the UFC.
And the significance of course is at Eddie Bravo.
Our guests today actually invented the twister.
I didn't invent it.
Well you invented rest set up the set setup the setups.
Yes.
The finishing move.
No.
And you called the wrestling mode,
but people used to finish people within wrestling.
You can,
but did they do it your way with the escrow on the forehead?
I thought that was all like your,
your uh,
innovation to turn into a submission.
Ah,
no,
no.
People were cranking,
cranking in exactly the way I crank it,
but I'm pretty sure.
Um,
did you,
had you seen other people get submitted with it before you ever started doing
it?
We would like to in high school,
I wrestled a couple of years and then I wrestled in Santa Anna High and in ninth
grade a guy named Jesse Barrios and another guy,
his buddy is the one who showed me,
I can't remember his name,
I couldn't even remember it for my book.
But Jesse Barrios is his friend,
Santa Ana high school in 1985 if anybody out there is from that,
there's Jesse Barrios friend,
the other leg rider on that wrestling team.
Fuck,
I don't know what his name is.
Anyways,
he showed it to me and both of those and in wrestling,
leg riding is for weak people and all that means is as we need,
we're so weak.
We need to use our legs a lot more than the big strong dudes who are wrestling
and,
and hitting the weights and had big chest and shoulders.
Those guys really didn't rely on their legs as much as the weak guys like me.
I would skip Russ,
uh,
weightlifting a practice.
I was in the back where I was hiding.
I was,
I was weak.
Even back then.
I was a terrible athlete.
I've never been a great athlete.
So I had to rely on using my legs.
And I thought,
you know,
they came to me,
Jesse came to me and I go,
dude,
you'll be perfect for this.
You know,
cause they knew I just get out,
just get smashed if I try to go heads up with people.
So it's a pending move in that I learned in wrestling and um,
I got,
I got pretty good at it.
I would,
that was my shit even in high school.
That was my,
that was the thing I always tried.
I got some cool ass stories that maybe one day I'll,
I'll,
I'll uh,
I'll talk about him,
but I have some cool wrestling stories.
But anyways,
I sucked at wrestling.
I only had one take down two fucking years.
I sucked.
So I just totally relied on leg riding and,
and using the,
it's actually called the guillotine.
It's actually not called the twister,
it's called the guillotine.
But when I started doing an end Jujitsu Higgin Machado and John John Machado
would just call it the twister because the guillotine already existed.
There's a lot of people out there that,
that think that I'd like took this wrestling move and I said,
I'm going to try to fool the world and change the name and say I invented it.
There's thousands of people that think that it's hilarious.
In my books from day one,
I I,
it was to hold on a second.
You're being a little bit modest because you invented all these setups and
turned it into a very high percentage finish.
Yeah.
Answered a lot of setups from a lot of different places where it became,
I mean,
do it.
Then none of that stuff existed,
but this is the transition.
So I ended up
quitting wrestling.
The work,
the work,
the work will,
the work ethic.
You need to be a good wrestler or something that is just not in my body.
Chemistry,
I was not made to work really hard physically I,
I just,
I hated work.
Regular jobs.
I knew that's why it was all about rock stardom or,
or playing football.
It was a,
I just want her to be like a famous dude who just played for a living and got
paid and was a fucking adored by everybody.
That's what I wanted.
I didn't want to work.
I hate it.
Or of course,
who doesn't want,
Oh my God would work like actually like killed me inside.
So it drove my artistic side.
Okay.